Not so long ago, the question “should we
teach patriotism in schools?” would have
seemed a strange one.
The answer would have been “of course!”
Today, the role of patriotism in schooling is
controversial, generally supported on the right
and greeted skeptically by many on the left.
Those of us who embrace patriotism believe
that students need to appreciate the sacrifices
so many have made to secure our freedoms
and all that unites as as Americans.
Indeed, a healthy patriotism is inextricably
bound to American civic health.
To skeptics, “patriotism” is a term freighted
with partisanship, tinged with xenophobia,
and often viewed as a divisive rhetorical ploy.
Regardless of these larger debates, though, I think
that most Americans would agree that students
should learn about all what's worth cherishing
in our rich history, and also the many, many ways
we can do better in extending and
upholding the American legacy.
In the end, whether we call that “patriotism”
or something else may just be semantics.
What does "patriotic education" mean to you?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and SUBSCRIBE for more
research and videos from AEI.